amira manchiaro was arrested in the
ethiopian capital addis ababa accused of
promoting terrorism he was working as a
freelance journalist for the associated
press
the us-based news agency has called the
allegations baseless two other
journalists were also arrested they face
up to 15 years in prison if convicted of
violating the emergency laws brought in
last month
the annual global roundup by reporters
without borders paints a bleak picture
of media safety and freedom particularly
in ethiopia
the correspondent of the new york times
has been kicked out of the country which
was unprecedented since abby took office
in in
2018 there is this communication
blackout in the northern part of the
country and now we are just not able to
do independent journalism anymore
because only the official narrative
about the war is allowed for journalists
it's been a tough year for journalists
around the world reporters without
borders says at least 46 journalists
have been killed this year because of
the stories they were reporting and
nearly 500 are being detained
65 are being held hostage the most
dangerous countries for media workers
are mexico and afghanistan followed by
yemen and india
one of the reason why there are so many
journalists detained this year up to 20
percent is mainly because the
deterioration of the situation in three
countries including myanmar and china
and the belarus
reporters without borders says its
findings are alarming but remarkably the
number of journalists killed this year
is the lowest since it began counting 25
years ago but the number of journalists
being detained is the highest and in
their absence it says vital voices
remain silent
victoria gatenby al jazeera